pour les aviser la terre offre le plus
beau des spectacles
olivier grunewald quatre fois
récipiendaire du prestigieux prix du
world press photo a pourtant été formé à
la photo publicitaire avant de se
tourner vers la nature effectivement
j'ai eu cette découverte de la nature
avec un premier voyage en islande
et là ça a été la confrontation avec les
forces de la terre et ça a été le point
de départ en me disant que j'allais
essayer de de faire un travail avec une
quête de lumière sur ces paysages
l'exposition originale réuni 60 de ses
photographies prises au cours des trente
dernières années
durant ses voyages aux quatre coins de
la planète en compagnie de sa conjointe
la journaliste bernadette gilbert passe
avec qui il partage sa passion c'est
vrai que de voyager comme ça offre une
liberté en fait un champ de liberté qui
est assez aux immenses donc quand on
revient après essayer de se glisser dans
une vie un peu plus traditionnel
on la trouve antho étroite l'exposition
origines est une invitation au voyage
dans le temps divisé en quatre chapitres
le premier ko et voit que le chaos des
origines où la terre est en pleine
effervescence en pleine formation grâce
au volcanisme actif la terre va
s'assagir et le deuxième chapitre arrive
terre où on présente
les paysages
que les éléments commencent à sculpter
et puis au fur et à mesure la vie va
apparaître et donc sous forme végétale
et voici donc le chapitre oasis qui
évoque peut-être un peu le jardin d'éden
est quatrième et dernier chapitre
l'apparition et l'évolution du monde
vivant qu'on intitulé vestiaires moi je
pense qu'on ne peut pas être blasé
quand il s'agit de d'admirer la nature
parce que la nature est changeante
un amour sincère de la nature qu'ils
espèrent transmettre aux visiteurs
la situation de la planète est quand
même extrêmement critique et il faut
amener par la beauté aussi pas être que
dans des situations on va montrer des
choses extrêmement terrible youssry
montré que la beauté est peut-être que
la beauté sauvera le monde
origine est assurément une hotte
photographique à la beauté du monde ici
n'est bien alexandre chartier radio
canada montréal